hello and welcome to see your plane
Dexter Morgan Oh Dexter s co inc going
to the Sicilian okay oc3 hats not so
exciting I came I'm willing to suffer in
the French defense I don't like the iqp
positions all that much so maybe we can
go for this he actually knows what he's
doing yeah you guys start with Knight f3
and then know the CC c 3 design what has
the world come to I have to admit that I
don't know much M might be five I go
queen d 8 which is not completely
enthusiastic about all this I think if
he takes I probably have to take on c5
and if you grab chatting with a king mmm
[Music]
yeah i might like this position and
surprisingly and so this one it's not
spend an hour here is going to Castle
long maybe King e7 then a six-minute it
should not be that bad okay now is 6m
and I want to get rid of this friggin
night he just goes goes in
ok so we will get the bishop Pam check
hmm yeah that should be a bit better for
white but what I habits i have a pretty
decent centralization so no I don't
think I'm in bad shape Bishop d6 will
also trade this one pretty much Bishop
age for I just an f6 that will not do
all that much for him yeah ok I think
I'm the Ithaca in a reasonable spot IAM
ok mentor interesting so go to you for
why is that an idea
okay 87 is not hanging I can try Knight
to c4 may be unsure but it's something
that I can try
trying to provoke some weaknesses on the
queenside the other idea that certainly
was possible was moving my mighty five
night as I was a bit quicker on the D
file so let's see what this is
interesting right how does he handle
look it just takes it okay
okay f5 is a bit and comfortable looking
so I'm going to stop at five yes 95 but
not sure if this is a very threatening
yeah I need to trade one who p.m. let's
see 9 to be six then traded on we would
that night be positioned well I want g5
also i think i go here and then trade
look
[Music]
before an option and it's a tick tick
his pawns
okay cannot go to see 5 or anything so f
6 takes away some squares yeah I
understand but I know I'm not taking the
night is weird on before so it's reroute
and then ultimately 930 649 f5 those
kind of things his pawn structure is a
little bit a little bit worse not not so
easy to handle so 96 on in five as a
move let's go there and show
you
I don't know if I wanted to I was
thinking about a five but I don't know
if this is actually doing much let's
play it this is interesting I don't know
if he wants to coach a b3 this is really
a weird square yeah and here I'm doubled
attacking and in a very inconvenient way
the rook has no squares efore runs into
a fork you have to go to be three check
okay so if i take this it's that winning
on I can also go b6 it's not bad for
Roxy for lighting besides yeah I know
sometimes you have I have those matchups
that don't work for one opponent this is
my seventh win out of 7 games against
Dexter so it seemed Jim it was I think
equal ish for a long time maybe it was
better in the opening that's very likely
actually I don't know the theory here I
don't know how this is played I mean
here he could have played this of course
immediately I think this is a known
opening line and we got something very
similar this this I went back it took
gym check it looks a little bit
uncomfortable I am it really does this
one computer I am that's a I am 94
that's probably stronger because I don't
really have fantastic squares i mean if
i go here you can do yes yeah it's
better for white
check this i feel i'm ok i'm i'm
reasonably well developed and
coordinated so now after the trade wow
the engine wants to take age seven right
now if you consider that same that's a
completely unhuman over it don't newman
would take them so okay this one lets
you form yeah probably this is what the
engine says is just equal i need to
trade one route that makes sense so that
i can use both rook rook and night giant
here it should be equal ish but okay
night III was already good and i didn't
think about that yeah but it makes makes
perfect sense yeah get the nigeria five
quickly LG form now yeah i could have
played a five immediately because here
the book doesn't have squares either we
prepare data and now he has to go to be
three and i would if the engine wants to
play books yet i would have played be 6
cm and just ask him what this thing is
doing exactly potential idea also night
you form as the engine gives this is a
bit better for black effort if you win
or not tough to say and yeah i'm just
picking up the exchange check rook takes
you five might win here but it is
unnecessary to calculate i'll just do
this and pick up even more stuff ok guys
thanks for watching